kevin we know that crowdfunding is all
the rage kickstarter indiegogo
and other sites that are wonderful
but what if someone does not want a
crowdfund it's not as easy as just
posting the campaign there's a lot of
work it's like a full-time job
can you talk about other ways of funding
grants what have you
well i've been lucky to find
private money to fund my documentaries
but
there are more traditional sources and
that's generally teaming up with either
a production company or a network
you know it's a traditional way you go
and you pitch a network hbo what have
you and they're going to go into
business with you that's
ideally the way you do things that's not
easy either
so these other avenues have come along
grants i've never
done because you need the patience of
job to do that that takes forever and
your and the money is coming in in very
small
amounts it's possible i have a good
friend doing a documentary
now on wc handy and she received money a
grant money and so she's
you know she's been filming as she goes
along so it is possible
um the crowd funding
is also difficult i've had three friends
who have successfully funded at various
price points
up from thirty five thousand up to two
hundred thousand dollars
and that's very rare but it's it's
doable on
in kickstarter or indiegogo
um and and then you know there's
there's uh so there's private
individuals
that's another form that i found uh
that's also difficult but
it does cut through a lot of the back
and forth with
grants or networks or what have you so
it's that's always the number one
question and and the toughest thing is
how do you get the money to make these
things so
you know it's it's really going out to
the marketplace and finding out what
they're going to say well what's in it
for them can they make money off this
enterprise it's it's are they going to
be able to see the return on their
dollar on their investment
um so that's why you consider these
things when you're picking your topics
you know you want to you want to look at
the marketplace and say
is there room in the market for this
documentary is there has there been
competition on the subject
if so uh is there room for one more if
not
it was a reason nobody wanted to do this
topic so you're going to look at all
that
you know as you go into funding but it's
always the most difficult thing
there are new ways to do it i wouldn't
say no to the crowdsourcing because
if you have a good pitch and you have a
good idea and you maybe only need funds
to either get started or finish maybe 35
or 50 thousand dollars
that's pretty doable i had some some
friends who needed finishing funds of
200 and they raised 210 or so so
it is possible to to do if you have an
appealing subject
let's say though you'd like to go the
route of pitching a network or
an individual that would like to invest
in a film
what do you need to have in place when
you show up i know something like that
they were going to want to see
complete organization and right in my in
my experience they don't they want to
see a written pitch but they don't want
it to be 40 pages they want it to be
between 5 and 10 pages that they can get
the idea of your film that quickly
and nowadays if you could put any kind
of
pitch reel together sizzle reel kind of
trailer i know you haven't shot it yet
supposedly but maybe you can
maybe for free on your own dime you can
go down to your subject and get an
afternoon with them and get them on tape
and if you shoot it with your hd slr and
you
and you cut it on your your cloud
editing system
you put it together for very little and
you have their stills which you can
license
and you so you put together a little
two-minute pitch movie
along with a five-page pitch that's all
you need you they're gonna get it from
that
so at least come in with those two
things and and you have a shot
you